[Music]
puerto rico is my home
i've really devoted a lot of my life and
career to protecting puerto rico's
natural resources
[Music]
so when hurricane irma and maria hit
puerto rico there was devastation
throughout the entire island
and so this is something that i felt
that we really had to address and take
action
commercial fishermen in puerto rico are
providing the base to a lot of economic
growth
while every industry was really affected
fishing communities were severely
impacted
a lot of fishing gear that was
near shore
was pulled back into the ocean by the
hurricane
this is something that was of great
personal concern just because this
causes them to be ghost trapped
ghost traps are a real problem for the
marine environment because they continue
fishing so they're catching fish and
other other species that die off
serve no purpose for the marine
environment and have no benefit to
commercial fishermen
we really wanted to see how we could
address helping out fishing communities
while at the same time cleaning up this
derelict fishing gear
we really wanted to collaborate with
dive fishermen in puerto rico because of
this incredible knowledge that they have
that nobody else has of the sea floor
and because we wanted to provide an
alternative income during the aftermath
of hurricane maria to really help them
move forward
[Music]
when the fishermen go out fishing
they're under water collecting fish and
while they're down there they identify
where ghost traps are located and then
they'll give me a call
[Music]
so i'll come out the next day or two and
start pulling up this gear
the fishermen are compensated for their
time and they're really brought as
collaborators on the project
we cover all of puerto rico it's just
over 15 communities that have
participated in this effort
[Music]
we've been able to remove just under 400
uh ghost traps and it totals up to seven
tons of derelict fishing gear that we've
removed from puerto rico's ocean
[Music]
after the impact of hurricane maria we
really felt alone
but it really brought a lot of puerto
rico together
without the local knowledge of these
fishermen we would not have been able to
come together as a people to really
survive and move forward to see how
things can improve here and it's
something that we need to continue
recognizing not just for fishing
communities but for all response to
emergencies
[Music]
you